سنجاب
كلب وصراخ
معًا لجعل مقطع فيديو ينتشر بسرعة وأنا أعلم
أنني بصوت عالٍ أعرف أنني بغيض
ولكنني محرج حقًا لأن
جيراني كادوا يطلقون رجال الشرطة الذين
اعتقدوا أن هناك جريمة قتل يتم
ارتكابها ولكن ذلك  تم تنفيذ عملية الإنقاذ
عندما حوصر سنجاب
بين الشاشة والزجاج في
منزل آشلي كارين في ماساتشوستس ،
اسمع ، دعنا نبرم صفقة يا حبيبي ،
سأخرجك بأمان ،
سأفتح
هذا وأنت تسرع للخارج مرة
أخرى  إن حياتك الغريبة السعيدة التي تتفاوض
مع سنجاب قد أكسبت آشلي
لقب همس السنجاب غريب الأطوار
، لقد حذرت أطفالها في الغرفة الأخرى ،
حسنًا ، فقط ابقوا هناك ، حسنًا ، إذا صرخت ،
كل شيء على ما يرام ،
أوه ،
ربما هذا أفضل ، لا حسنًا ، حسنًا  حسنًا ، لقد
كنت على حق في المرة الأولى التي
كان فيها آشلي يصرخ بالقتل الدموي
ولكن السنجاب عاش ، اتضح أن رئيس
آشلي مالاموت في ألاسكا المسمى رئيسه هو الذي حمل
السنجاب إلى الشرفة بينما كان آشلي يحفظك
أعتقد أنه وضع اثنين
واثنين مع صراختي وكان
مثل ربما يجب أن أترك هذا الرجل الصغير
يبتعد عن الصراخ
الجزء المفضل لدى الجميع كان هذا الخط حسنًا إذا
صرخت كل شيء على ما يرام ، قال أحدهم
أنني أريد ذلك باعتباره
القميص ، هل ستفعل ذلك ، سأكون كاذبًا ، لكن
في النهاية صرخت وكان الأمر جيدًا على
الرغم من أنه ربما لم تكن الموسيقى على آذان
هذا السنجاب
العبقري cnn نيويورك